bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 les invités une
émission vous le savez pour découvrir
celles et ceux qui font l'actualité dans
le département est aujourd'hui parole à
michel laugier le président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
l'agglomération vient de lancer un
nouveau site internet peps un site
internet pour permettre aux particuliers
aux entreprises d'effectuer des
démarches administratives en ligne vous
l'entendrez vous entendrez aussi dans
cette émission philippe bihouix co
auteur du livre le désastre de l'école
numérique il viendra nous expliquer
pourquoi selon lui numérique le
numérique n'est pas forcément une bonne
chose pour les écoliers
mon début de 7,8 les invités avec le
nouveau site internet de l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines peps ce
nouvel outil numérique lancée en début
de semaine dans le cadre de la semaine
de l'innovation publique permet aux
particuliers aux entreprises d'effectuer
un certain nombre de démarches
administratives en ligne plus de
précisions avec michel laugier le
président divers droite de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
présentez moi ce portail qui s'appelle
peps le peps alors dans le cadre de la
semaine de l'innovation nous avons
souhaité mettre en place un nouveau
service en ligne pour la population de
50 on devine donc le peps portail espace
public service va permettre aux usagers
du territoire d'avoir leurs démarches
facilitées
alors on va l'étendre bien sûr à la
totalité des services mais on a commencé
dans son jeu mettant par tout ce qui est
concerne les réseaux réseaux
assainissement et éclairage public dont
tout simplement les habitants de saint
quentin qui sont face
j'ai qui touche ce domaine là pour
intervenir directement en ligne bien sûr
sans avoir remplir deux grands
formulaire données de la démoralisation
donc la veille pourront intervenir tout
de suite ils ont une réponse présente
pour un raccordement au réseau s'ils
vont construire une maison
s'il ya des défaillances dont
l'éclairage public et bien ils pourront
intervenir directement auprès de nos
services
de même pour les prestataires de la côte
de thé d'agglomération les sociétés qui
interviennent aussi à titre
professionnel pourront aussi faire cette
démarche
c'était vraiment une demande des
saint-quentinois
c'est une demande d'essai gras dur parce
que on voit que les démarches sont
nombreuses mais pour le moment est le
centre et matériels donc baisse de
papier donc là c'est pour faciliter
toutes ces choses là leur demande des
saint quentinois mais aussi demande des
entreprises et qui interviennent de ce
notre territoire et cette envie de des
mains dématérialisée tout au fur et à
mesure expliqué moi pourquoi tout
simplement parce que vous vois bien deux
sommets l'ère du numérique donc
aujourd'hui on voit bien même regarder
tout le monde travaille sur internet
tout le monde à ses mails tout le monde
à ses messages bien nous nous essayons
que toutes les démarches administratives
au même titre que l'état savait
maintenant on va pouvoir faire ces
demandes de cartes d'identité en ligne
nous c'est la même chose on essaie de
simplifier toutes les tâches pour que
les choses soient plus rapides ce soit
plus efficace c'est que ce soit plus en
adéquation avec les moyens que nous
avons aujourd'hui à disposition alors
peps ou m'avait dit il ya une première
partie que vous avez mis en place et la
suite c'est quoi écouter la suite on va
développer sur l'ensemble des services
aujourd'hui gérée par l'état comme l'a
dit et ce sera par exemple la collecte
des ordures ménagères les déchetteries
voilà toutes les compétences qui sont
les nôtres seront ensuite donc
accessible en ligne pour faciliter la
vie des usagers de 50 ans d'evelyne donc
ça compte combien d'acteurs qui va
participer à ce site tout le tout le
monde tout le monde veut dire du à tous
les saint gaudinois avec eux doute les
compétences qui sont celles d'une
agglomération
qui part de l'aménagement donc
d'urbanisme qui passe par le social qui
passe par la culture le sport donc tous
les domaines seront concernés et nous
allons essayer d'avoir un produit un
support qu'ils soient très attractif et
très facilitateur et pour finir ce site
pop sont l'utilisent comment elle est
simple d'utilisation très simple isation
même moi j'arrive voilà tout simplement
dont vous allez soit sur le site de la
ville soit vous tapez sur moteur de
recherche
pep's saint quentin en yvelines et vous
allez voir et en quelques clics vous
avez la réponse à toutes vos questions
il plutôt cool ce nom oui c'est plus ou
pas bah oui mais je crois qu'on voulait
donner un peu d'eux un peu de peps à
d'autres vies à 50 ans d'evelyne je
crois que le don est tout à fait bien
trouvé merci à vous à l'invité nous a
rejoint à présent en plateau philippe
bihouix bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
ingénieur et co auteur de ce livre qu'on
voit à l'écran le désastre de l'école
numérique un livre plutôt d'étonnant
puisqu'il va à l'encontre de la tendance
actuelle sur le numérique à l'école
puisque vous dites un en gros je résume
le numérique à l'école ce n'est pas bon
pour les élèves tout le monde se trompe
et notamment le gouvernement
alors expliquez nous pourquoi et
pourquoi surtout employé le mot con
voilà le mot désastre est un mot qui est
fort or le moindre effort a
effectivement mais parce que sur de très
nombreuses dimensions
nous estimons que l'école numérique pose
de vraies questions à la première
évidemment c'est la question pédagogique
est ce qu'on apprend mieux avec le
numérique
malheureusement on s'aperçoit que
derrière les promesses des rapports qui
s'enchaînent et des fabricants il ya en
réalité très peu de choses et très peu
d'études qui permettent de montrer que
ça permet d'augmenter les performances
la motivation et les processus
d'apprentissage
le peu de choses qu'on a quand on
regarde des études un peu importante
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de corrélation
entre l'effort de numérisation des
systèmes scolaires de différents pays et
de résultats en termes de performances
donc on a très peu de choses aient envie
plutôt sur des promesses et ce n'est pas
la première fois qu'on nous fait des
promesses d'ailleurs puisque dans
l'histoire vous savez les fabricants ont
proposé des lanternes magiques lire à la
radio la télévision le cinéma et puis
tous les plans nuit les plans
informatique on l'appelait encore qu'une
et enchaîner quand vous utilisez le mot
désastre
forcément on entend aussi le mot danger
derrière est ce que ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui les écoliers qui
utilisent le numérique à l'école sont
sont exposées en quelque sorte à une
forme de danger ce que vous allez y est
jusque là alors il ya plusieurs choses
on pourrait prendre au niveau un petit
peu globale et pas seulement chez nos
enfants
la question écologique et là on peut
vraiment parler argument numéro un les
colonies
c'est un des arguments c'est à dire que
effectivement cela est incontestable
c'est que équipé des millions d'élèves
d'un outil numérique qui va avoir une
obsolescence programmée ou technique
parce qu'on sait qu'il faut suivre
l'innovation technologique et tout ça
deviendra rapidement des déchets bien
plus vite que les manuels tout le monde
ne vit pas l'école numérique de la même
manière quand on travaille chez année
aux esclavagistes taiwanais en chine
pour monter la tablette ou quand on
termine en afrique de l'ouest pour
démonter les équipements mais quand on
parle de nos élèves ya aussi la question
sanitaire effectivement alors sans
tomber dans la question des des électro
fréquence même s'il ya un rapport récent
de la ss les électro fréquences en
rappel ce que c'est alors c'est la
maison de seconde qui sont émises par
voilà par le wifi par le 3g vers la 4g
etc
quand on vit dans un bouillon d'onde
alors on va dire un peu plus un peu
moins peu importe mais il trouve quand
même qu'il ya des il ya des risques et
notamment pour auch et les plus jeunes
enfants et quand on voit qu'on commence
à équiper les maternelles après les
primaires et les collèges aujourd'hui le
plan numérique il est centré sur le
collège mais on descend vers la
maternelle il ya même des crèches qui
ont des coins tablette là on peut se
poser des questions sanitaires et le
vrai risque selon nous c'est la question
des risques psychosociaux servir
justement j'avais vous posez la question
c'est quoi des risques psychosociaux
alors c'est le fait que nos enfants
passent déjà beaucoup trop de temps
devant des écrans 1 c'est 4 à 5 heures
les étudiants rien peu mais c'est de cet
ordre là
en dehors de l'école en dehors de
l'école et qu'est ce que va faire
décoller mais qu'est ce que fait l'école
numérique d'une part elle va rajouter du
temps d'écran parce qu'on va faire une
partie des cours devant un écran elle va
inciter ou obliger les enfants à as à se
connecter après la classe parce qu'il
faut aller sur le qualité que ceux
numérique il faut aller sur internet
pour faire ces exposés pour faire ses
devoirs et surtout et légitime le temps
d'écran vis-à-vis des parents c'est à
dire que puisqu'il ya des écrans à
l'école les écrans c'est bien et c'est
bien de te connecter le soir mon fils ou
ma fille parce que ça permet de faire
des bonnes études et de faire tes
devoirs
est-ce que vous soyez aussi au delà du
de l'école dire que ça change nos
rapports entre nous entre
être humain par exemple on va plus se
diriger vers sa tablette après l'école
peut-être que peut faire les devoirs
avec son copain alors sur la question
sociologique en gros il ya 80 vous aviez
des collégiens qui rentrait chez aupic
appelé leurs copains ou leurs copines au
téléphone être d'être sur internet c'est
pas forcément être seul jeudi par contre
ce qui est clair c'est qu'il ya un
phénomène d'addiction possible soit aux
réseaux sociaux soit aux jeux vidéo par
exemple
et on sait que quand on va se brancher
ou dans la semaine sur son ordinateur
pour faire ses devoirs
en général c'est dans la société du
multitâche dans laquelle on vit on fait
pas que ses devoirs et on va aller aussi
un petit peu se balader à gauche à
droite quand on va regarder une vidéo de
classe un verset du professeur parce que
c'est un petit peu la main en ce moment
vous savez vous regardez le le cours à
la maison et puis vous allez faire en
classe d exercice et bien tous les
élèves ne vont pas regarder avec le même
niveau de concentration
donc ça peut même créer des inégalités
supplémentaires en fonction de
l'attention parental que vous allez
avoir justement par exemple l'objectif
du gouvernement qui veut équiper 100 %
des collégiens d'une tablette c'est de
réduire la fracture numérique puisqu'il
ya des petits écoliers qui n'ont pas
forcément accès au numérique chez eux et
du coup on réduira les inégalités
cet argument là aussi vous ne croyez pas
il a du sens pourtant alors on est passé
sur autre chose en n'est plus tellement
sur la fracture numérique en termes
d'équipement ça c'est vrai que c'était
des choses vraies dans les plans des
années 80 90 ou même du début des années
2000 aujourd'hui tout le monde reconnaît
toutes les études montrent que les
enfants grosso modo ont accès à peu près
à toutes les sortes d'équipements et
haut débit internet est en fait les
inégalités se sont quasiment inversés
c'est à dire que dans les milieux les
plus défavorisés vous allez avoir accès
à un écran plus rapidement et plus
rapidement dans votre chambre
c'est extrêmement dangereux comment ça
s'explique ça alors ça s'explique
peut-être par des questions de de dison
de normes sociales par des questions de
par des questions de
d'attention parental par exemple vous
connaissez peut-être cette anecdote avec
les les pontes de la silicon valley qui
essayent de protéger l'entente dans un
livre essaie de protéger leurs cadres de
la silicon valley inscrivent leurs
enfants dans des écoles sans écran donc
là c'est le monde à l'envers
voilà alors c'est un petit peu il ya un
petit côté anecdotique est d'enfer et un
petit peu il ya une petite accroche mais
effectivement c'était notamment un
article du new york times qui avait un
journaliste qui l'avait interrogé au
steve jobs et qui ensuite avait enquêté
sur ces questions là où il ya une
question de l'école privée aux etats
unis qui fait qu'ils aient des écoles du
réseau à steiner waldorf et voilà
souvent il ya effectivement moins
d'écrans dans ces écoles mais c'est vrai
que c'est c'est une énorme est question
de de dire est ce que est ce que le
processus d'apprentissage par un écran
est possible ça reste que la relation
est ce qu'on n'est pas en train d'abîmer
ou de préparer les conditions techniques
pour abîmer la relation enseignants
enseigne et enfin la relation
professeurs et élèves
est-ce que vous ayez jusqu'à dire qu'il
faut une école sans numérique du tout
revenir à ce qui était le cas pour
détient il ya 10 ou 15 ans alors pour
nous il s'agit pas forcément de parce
que ça fait longtemps maintenant quand
on a des ordinateurs dans les classes
mais est-ce qu'il faut revenir à 0 %
numérique
alors il ya ça fait longtemps que les
ordinateurs qui traînent dans les
classes qui a des choses dans les
laboratoires de langues la classe
numérique et cetera mais c'était que il
ya quand même aujourd'hui le plan
numérique s'agit quand même d'équiper
l'ensemble des élèves d'un outil qui
sera deviendra leur cartable numérique
donc on est quand même dans une logique
de généralisation et il ya une volonté
exprimée par le président françois
hollande de de numériser l'ensemble des
matières y compris l'éducation physique
et sportive c'est à dire qu'il va
falloir se filmer sur tablette
maintenant pour corriger le passage de à
quoi vous êtes pour une nuance vous donc
on n'est pas pour le retour à l'école
d'avant quand on quand on parle d'un
plaidoyer pour une école sens écran
c'est pas d'école d'avant l'école
d'avant elle est déjà en crise on sait
qu'il ya un sujet la crise de la tension
de la motivation du décrochage des
élèves
aujourd'hui on utilise le vecteur
numérique pour essayer de bousculer
l'approché pédagogique dans l'ensemble
des matières mais on n'est pas obligé de
faire ça on peut faire de l'innovation
numérique on peut faire de la production
de contenu par son tweet et spatiaux
connaissez les tweets et alors cédé on
peut on peut publier les profs publier
les meilleurs les meilleures
réalisations de leurs élèves sur compte
twitter a lancé et c'est agréable quand
on a un enfant un adolescent d'être
publié on peut faire des choses avec un
journal de l'école on peut faire des
classes inversée en lisant les manuels
et c'est donc à une vraie innovation non
humains
qui est possible dernière question une
réponse très rapide s'il vous plaît est
ce que ce qui n'est pas nécessaire non
plus c'est plus de pédagogie envers
envers les élèves leurs dires les
méfaits du numérique
absolument c'est à dire que si on est
tout à fait d'accord que le monde est
numérisé il faut préparer les citoyens
au monde de demain et donc l'éducation
au numérique est indispensable mais nous
serons conteste et l'éducation par le
numérique ces terres sous pretexe
d'apprendre le numérique on doit faire
ça dans toutes les matières et ce à tous
les âges et le plus tôt possible à
l'image par exemple des cours de
programmation au cm1 qui vont être
introduits par le nouveau plan numérique
programmation ses mains alors qu'on pour
apprendre le langage le soi-disant
langage informatique alors qu'on
maîtrise même pas sa langue maternelle
merci philippe bihouix d'avoir répondu à
nos questions c'est la fin de ce set 8
les invités une émission à revoir en
replay sur notre site internet tv fil 78
points comme rendez vous sinon demain à
la même heure